وعلى الصيد الميداني اعلنت القوات الموليه
لروسيا سيطرتها الكامله على كامل محيط
المطار
وقالت تلك الوحدات انها احكمت قبضتها على
اخر معاقل قوات الحكوميه الاوكرانيه التي
كانت تتمركز خلف المدرج ونشرت قوه دونيت
كاسورا للعمليه مشيره الى انها جارات بدعم
من فرقه المدفعيه الروسيه
اين الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه اسقط طائره
مسيره فوق مياه البحر الاسود
نعم تحيه طيبه سلمى
الامس مساء ان اعلن ااا مولونا لروسيا
قوات الدفاع الذاتي هنا عن انها تمكنت من
السيطره على اخر معاقل القوات الاوكرانيه
في محيط مطار دونيتك الدولي باعتبار ان
تلك القوات تسيطر على مبنى المطار
والمباني الملحقه به منذ عام 2015 لكن
مدرج المطار كان فعليا هو خط التماس
الفاصل بين الجانبين على مدى ثماني سنوات
من الصراع هنا في اقليم جمباز هناك ايضا
جبهه اخرى يقول لروسيا انهم حققوا تقدم
فيها وهي جبهه بلده همم
حيث تحدث وسائل الاعلام محليه موليه
لروسيا عن اقتحام هذه البلده من قبل
قواتنار وانها تقوم الان بتمشيط هذه
البلده الهامه والاستراتيجيه لعده اعت
اولها انها عقده مواصلات وطرق همم هامه
تربط بين لي سيتشانز في مقاطعه لوغانسك
وطابازنا ايضا في مقاطعه لوكاسك مع كل من
مع كل من باخموت وايضا سوليدار على ذلك
باقي الجبهات هناك عمليات كروا وفر اذا
صحه تعبير خاصه في محور اوغلي دار وفي
محور ايضا افديفكا مع تسجيل التبادل للقذف
مستمر حتى هذه اللحظه في الحقيقه سما
وتصلونها اصوات رجيمات الصواريخ والمدفعيه
الثقيله على اطراف مدينه دنيا
والاخرى اليوم السلطات المواليه لروسيا
هنا في دنياك قالت ان مدنيا واحده قتل
وجرح عدد اخر جراء قصف في تعارضت له احياء
بتروسكي وكويبيسكي وكيف هنا في هذه
المدينه اضافه الى استهداف مدن اخرى ايضا
قريبه همم الى جبهات القتال وهي ياسين
وايضا بعض البلدات التي تقع الى جنوب
مندونيسكو هذه البلده في حقيقه دائما ما
تتعرض لقصف باعتبار انها قريبه من خطوط
همم التماس عدد ذلك ايضا هناك محاولات
متواصله من قبل القوات الروسيه اللي همم
لربما تضييق الخناق على القوات الاوكرانيه
في محور اوبلدار بلده بابلو في القريبه من
هذه المدينه ما زالت لم يعني لم تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه كما قالت في وقت
سابق وكانت ايضا قد نفت همم انها تعرضت
لخسائر فادحه كما قال او كما كان الجانب
الاوكراني قد اعلن عن ذلك في وقت سابقا
عامر لفي كيف بدا الموقف حيث انتم
بالنسبه للتطور عند مطار تونس لم تذكر
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه او قياده الجيش
هنا اي معلومات بهذا الخصوص حولنا التواصل
لم يجيبوا بشكل صريح وانما قالوا اننا
مازلنا في مواقعنا ولا تغيير على حدود هذه
الجبهه الامر الاخر بخصوص القريه للتحدث
عنها امين بالقريفيكا ايضا قياده الاركان
ذكرتها اليوم في البيان اليومي لقياده
الاركان بانه تم الصدمه هجوم روسي على هذه
البلده نذكر طبعا
مدينه الشمس الى الجنوب الغربي من هذه
المدينه وكاله القوات الروسيه قدسيطرت
عليها في وقت سابق لكن تعلم عند انسحاب
الدراماتيكي للقوات الروسيه من شرقيه
وشمال دونيس ايضا انسحبت من حوالي تسعه
مدن او تسع بلدان يعني يقول من مقاطعه
لوجانسي هي احدى هذه البلدان ومنذ ذلك
اليوم وهي اا تتعرض لقصف شديد من جانب
القوات الروسيه ومحاولات مستمره لدخول هذه
البلده لكن كما ذكرت قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه ما زالت تؤكد بانها تمكنت من
صد الهجمات المتكرره وهجمه مساء الامس على
هذه البلده التي ما زالت بهذه القوات
الاوكرانيه كما يقول عموما طبعا على طول
الخطوط الجبهه عبد الصمد ما زالت المعارك
مستمره قياده الاركان تحدثت عن تمكينها من
صدق تسع محاولات للتقدم في مقاطعه طبعا
يبقى ان اعنف هذه المحاولات واعمل هذه
الجبهات الجبهات مخمود التي وفقا لمصادر
وكرانيه قالوا لنا بانه يوميا يكون هناك
على الاقل محاولتين كبيرتين للتقدم الروسي
هجوم واسع وانهم يتمكنوا من صاد هذا
الهجوم على مدينه مخمود التي تقصف ايضا
كمدينه بشكل يوميا على سبيل المثال اليوم
همم حاكم هذه المدينه همم المقاطعه قال
انا ثلاثه مدنيين قتلوا في هموم المقاطعه
اثنين منهم في مدينه محمود لوحدها التي
غالبا ما تحظى بعدد الاكبر من القتلى في
صفوف المدنيين بسبب القصف المستمر على هذه
المدينه مع ان معظم سكانها تراها نحن كنا
قبل يومين هناك المدينه شبه فارغه لكن ما
زال هناك عدد من السكان وخصوصا من كبار
السن ما زالوا متمسكين بالبقاء في المدينه
وفي كل يوم يسقط من بينهم جرحه وقد لا
جراء القصف المستمر على مدينه محمود شكرا
لك يا عامر لا في مراسله جزيره من كلام
ماتوس كما نشكر امين معنا من دونلز شكرا
لكم